تلعب وسياحه الزفاف دورا حيويا للشركات
العامله في قطاع السفر والسياحه وسجل حجم
السوق نحو 21 مليار و600 مليون دولار في
عام 2021 بحسب احدث بيانات لموقع استعان
من المتوقع ان يصل حجمها الى حولين 2011
مليار دولار بحلول عام 2031 سياحه الزفاف
شهدت نمو
75% في السنوات القليله الماضيه ونحو 25%
من حفلات الزفاف في العالم تجري خارج
المواطن الاصليه فيما يعرف بسياحه الزفاف
بالنسبه للازواج الامريكيين مثلا الارقام
تشير الى ان 40% من حفلاته زفافهم تتم في
وجهات خارجي»
لانها توفر للمسافرين فرصه المغامره الى
وجهاتنا متعدده والجمع بين الزفاف وشهر
العسل في مكان واحد وتعد ايطاليا اول مقصد
اوروبي يحتفل فيه العرسان بزفافهم خارجه
بلدانهم والثاني على الصعيد العالمي بعد
منطقه البحر الكاريبي تلهى فرنسا ثم
اليونان